i've talked a lot about how our change
in internal energy of a system
can be due to some heat being added to
the system or some
or some work being added to the system
or being done to the system and i'm
going to write it again the other way
just because you see it both ways you
could say that the change in internal
energy could be the heat added to the
system
minus the work done
by the system so there's two questions
that might naturally spring up in your
head one is how is heat added to or
taken away from a system and how is work
done or done done by or done to a system
the heat i think is fairly intuitive if
i have a
and will be a little bit we'll be more
precise in the future this but i just
want to give you the sense of what we're
talking about if i have some system here
some particles
in a
in some type of a canister
and it's at temperature
i don't know let's say it's a
temperature
t1
t1 i'll even give it i'll even give it a
measure say it's at a i don't know it's
at 300 kelvin
300 kelvin if i want to add heat to this
system what i can do is i can place
another system right next to it maybe
right next to it
you know who knows what size it is and
it's got
some particles there but its temperature
is much much much
higher
so this temperature is going to be
so this system's temperature let's say
temp t2 is equal to and let's say it's a
thousand kelvin i'm just making up
numbers so what's going to happen in
this situation you're going to have heat
transferred from
this second system to the first system
so you're going to have heat going into
the system
now heat
and
will work and even internal energy this
goes back to our conversation of
macrostates versus microstates heat is
changing the macro state of our systems
this system is going to lose temperature
the system is going to gain temperature
but we know what's happening on a micro
level these molecules are going to lose
kinetic energy these molecules are going
to gain kinetic energy how is that
actually happening well we assume that
there's some type of a container here
maybe it's a solid wall
these molecules are going to bump into
that wall they're going to make the
particles in that wall vibrate and then
they're going to make the particles
in the the green containers walls
vibrate and so when the green containers
molecules touch the wall they're going
to bounce off with even more kinetic
energy with even more velocity because
of that vibration in the wall will push
them back even further so that's
essentially how you get this transfer of
kinetic energy or this transfer of heat
i think that's fairly intuitive if we
put this next to a cooler
a a system with a lower temperature we
would lose kinetic energy or we would
lose heat there's other ways that we can
do it we could compress the contain well
i don't want to talk about that just now
because that will be touching on work so
how can we add or subtract work to a
system and this one's a little bit more
interesting let's go back to our piston
example
let's go back to a let me just draw some
lines here
so i have my container
there you go it's got a little movable
ceiling to it
that's our my piston
and go back to the example
because what we're going to be dealing
with especially once i go into the
pressure pressure volume diagram the pv
diagram that i'm about to go into we
want to deal with quasi-static processes
processes that are always close enough
to equilibrium that we feel okay
talking about macro states like pressure
and volume remember that if if we just
did something crazy and the whole system
is in flux those macro states aren't
defined anymore so let's say we're so we
want to do a quasi-static process so
i'll have pebbles instead of one big
rock i'll draw the pebbles a little
bigger this time
and i have some pressure
so that's my piston and it's
it's being kept down by these rocks
it's being kept up by the pressure of
the gas the gas is bumping into this
ceiling it's bumping into everything the
pressure at every point in the container
is the same it's at equilibrium
now what happens in that example where i
removed
i removed one rock from that so let me
copy and paste that
so if i remove one rock from this thing
right here
you copy and paste
so
that's the same thing now let me remove
a rock
i'll remove this top one was removed
what's going to happen well i now have
less weight pushing down on the piston
and i have a certain amount of pressure
pushing up the system it'll very
temporarily go out of equilibrium but we
did a very small uh difference in how
much we're pressing down on it so
hopefully it won't be a huge change in
our equilibrium we'll stay pretty close
to it
but we know from the previous example
instead of this thing flying up it's
going to shift up a little bit and this
is just going to shift up a little bit
right when we do it it's going to be
like
that right there and let me fill in
that part with black because it's not
like
the space disappeared
so let me fill that in right there
so our thing our little piston will move
up
a very small amount and what i claim is
when this happened when i removed this
little pebble
from here the system did some work and
let's just think about that
so work according to the definitions
that you learned in first year physics
and
when you just
do using classical or dealing with
classical mechanics you learn that work
is equal to
force
times distance
so if i'm claiming that when this piston
moved up a little bit when i remove that
pebble i'm claiming that this system
here did some work so i'm claiming that
it applied a force to this piston
and it applied that force to the piston
for some distance for some distance so
let's figure out what that is and if we
can somehow relate it to other macro
properties that we know reasonably well
well we know the pressure and the volume
right we know the pressure
that's being exerted on the piston at
least at this point in time and what's
pressure pressure
pressure
is equal to force per area
force
per area
right so the area remember this piston
there's some you know you're seeing it
from the side but it's a kind of a flat
plate or a flat ceiling on top of this
thing
and now what distance did it move it
let's just call that you know i could
blow it up a little bit let me
you know it moved it some i didn't draw
it too big here some x
some distance x
right so this change
it moved it moved it up some distance x
there
right
so what is the force that it pushed it
up well the force we know it's pressure
the pressure is force per area so if we
want to know the force
we have to multiply pressure times area
if we multiply both sides of this times
area
we get force
so we're essentially saying the area of
this little ceiling to this container
right there you know it could be i could
draw it with some depth but i think you
know what i'm talking about it has some
area it's probably the same area as the
base of the container
right so we could say that the force
being applied
by our system let me do it in a new
color the force
is equal to our pressure of the system
pressure times the area
of the ceiling times the area of the
ceiling of our of our container of the
piston
now that's the force now what's the
distance the distance is this x over
here
the distance is
i'll do it in blue
it's this change right here i didn't
draw it too big but that's
that x
now let's see if we can relate this
somehow let me draw a little bit bigger
so and i'll draw it i'll try to draw it
in three dimensions so let me draw the
piston what color did i do it in add it
in that brown color so our piston
looks something i'll draw it as a
ellipse
the piston looks like that
and it got pushed up
so it got pushed up some distance x let
me see how good i can know
whoops let me copy and paste that same
so the piston gets pushed up
some distance x
let me draw that
got pushed up some distance x
and we're claiming
that our oh sorry this is the force
sorry let me be clear this is the force
and this is the distance
right so work
is equal to our force which is our
pressure times our area
times the distance
right i wanted to be very clear with
that because when i wrote this i said
okay the force that we're applying is
the pressure we're applying times the
area of our cylinder
this is the area of our cylinder right
here
that's the area of our cylinder right
there so if you do the pressure
the pressure
times this area you get the force and
then we moved it some distance x
right
now what is we could rearrange this we
could say that the work is equal to our
pressure
times
our area times x
what's this
what's our this area
this area right here
times x
well that's going to be our change in
volume right we've increased this this
area times some height is some volume
and that's essentially how much our
container has changed in volume when we
push this piston up the volume of our
container has increased you can see that
even looking from the side our rectangle
got a little bit taller when you look at
it with a little bit of depth you see
the rectangle didn't also didn't get
taller we have some surface area surface
area times height is volume so this
right here this term right here is a
change
in volume
so we can write work now in terms of
things that we know
we can write work done by our system
work done is equal to
pressure
times our change in volume
times change
in volume now this has some this has a
very interesting
repercussion here so we could actually
many we can rewrite our internal energy
formulas
so for example we can write internal
change in internal energy is now equal
to heat added to the system
plus the work
plus the let me say the minus the work
done by the system
minus
the work done by the system well what is
the work done by the system what's the
pressure of the system times how much
the the system expanded
right in this case the system is pushing
these these these
these marbles or these these pieces of
sand up it's doing work if the if we're
doing the other way if we're adding the
sand and we're pushing down on our
little canister we would be doing work
to the system so this is the situation
where i'm doing here where i'm removing
the sand and the piston goes up
essentially the gas is pushing up on the
piston the system is doing the work
so if we go back to our little formula
that internal energy is heat minus the
work done by system so done by
done by then we could write this as this
is equal to
the heat added to the system heat added
minus
this quantity the pressure of the system
times the change in volume
it is interesting if the volume is
increasing then the system is doing work
and this applies we're going to talk a
lot more about engines in the future but
that's how engines do work they they
have a little explosion that goes on
inside of a cylinder that pushes up on
the piston and then that piston moves a
bunch of other stuff that eventually
turns wheels so when the volume
increases you're actually doing work
so i'm going to leave you there in this
video in the next video we're going to
relate this this new way of writing our
internal energy
our formula and we're going to relate it
to the pv diagram